hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast neuro anatomical
substrates underlying attentional
functional processing presented by dr.
Josh Burke I'm Susie Valdes of lab roots
and I will be your moderator for today's
event we are excited to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots so leading social scientific
social networks website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
here's how this presentation will work
today we want to hear from you questions
comments and even answers can be
submitted via the green Q&A button at
the lower left of your screen will try
to get to everyone but if not you will
make sure to follow up with you by email
you can also enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of this slide window
if you cannot hear or see the
presentation properly let us now by
clicking on the support button at the
top right or the Q&A button in the lower
left this is an educational webinar and
does offers free continuing education
credits after the webinar is over please
click on the c/e button located on the
bottom left hand corner of your web page
and follow the process of obtaining your
credit I would now like to introduce
today's speaker dr. Josh Burke associate
professor and chair of the department of
psychology at college of the William and
Mary professor Burke received a
bachelor's degree in psychology from the
University of California Davis his
master's and doctorate and experimental
psychology from the University of New
Hampshire and completed a post-doctoral
fellowship at The Ohio State University
he joined the William and Mary faculty
in 2002 where he is currently an
associate professor and chair professor
Burke was also the director of the
neuroscience program in 2011 to 2015 and
is currently as faculty affiliate in
that program professor Burke's
laboratory studied the neural basis of
attention learning memory and
impulsivity he is largely focused on the
role of cholinergic projections to the
cortex in the processes and how these
projections are regulated by
neuropeptides or xn
or hypocretin his laboratory has been
funded by grants from the NIH NAR sod
and Virginia tobacco settlement
foundation his research interests have
expanded the studying on how
neuro-diverse students can be more
accepted on campuses he has earned some
awards including the Phi Beta Kappa john
d rockefeller award of Advancement of
scholarship and a plumeria award faculty
excellent i would now like to turn the
presentation over to dr. Burke great
thank you Susie and thank you the lab
roots and organizers of this event for
the opportunity to speak with you today
on the title of my talk is Susie
mentioned is neuroanatomical substrates
underlying attentional processing and as
such I wanted to divide this talk up
into two different components during the
first part of the talk I'll discuss some
of the brain mechanisms that are
involved in the tensional processing and
then turn the latter part of my talk all
discuss a little about how the circuitry
becomes altered and neuropsychiatric
conditions in which attentional
processing is affected so to begin with
I wanted to describe what's been a large
focus of our efforts and other labs as
well trying to understand the role of
basal forebrain quote legal corner dick
neurons and attentional processing so
what you're looking at here is the
sagittal section a schematic of a
sagittal section of a plane and what's
being depicted as a an area here the
basal forebrain this is where cell
bodies are located that then project to
widespread areas of the cortex and
that's being depicted here too so we
study the role of different aspects of
this pathway in a measure of attention
so I want to take a minute to describe
this measure of attention because of Lee
something that I'll be discussing quite
a bit about my top so the way that the
task works is the rats routine are
trained in chambers that contain a
central panel light and that's being
depicted
you can see that right here and there
are two levers their potential that can
be extended and retracted one of the
levers is here and the other one is
right here so the way that the tennis
works is that I'm half the trials the
central panel light is illuminated in
most of our experiment this is for 500
125 milliseconds this can occur randomly
throughout the session if the lights
illuminated then a press on one of the
levers is considered correct in the
words that we cat with tap water and
most of our experiments I press on the
other level will be considered incorrect
will be scored a myth so correct rowdy
score is a hit and an incorrect trial be
scored as a Miss on the other half of
the trial there is no signal equivalent
so the central panel ID is not
illuminated now in these cases the rules
are reversed so press on the right lever
and this specific example would be
considered a correct rejection order the
customer left lever will be a false
alarm and considered incorrect and so
the animals need to detect whether or
not the light was illuminated other ways
that we make this task attention
demanding is that we vary the inner
trial interval so that the animals can't
time when specific trials are going to
happen and so we typically most of our
experiments this is 9 plus or minus 3
seconds of the entire trial integral so
just to give you a sense of general
performance miss task well on the y-axis
is showing percent accuracy iran signal
trials and sense of percent kids or
correct rejections of the accuracy on
the non signal trials and so for the
hits which you can see is the left
portion of the figure says log signal
links along the x axis and this is the
signal duration in this particular
experiment from look from Jill Maga hey
Martin Sardar they buried the signal
duration such that they were 550 and 25
milliseconds and so what would you see a
signal duration dependent performance of
accuracy higher follow longer signal
duration and decree accuracy decreasing
a shorter signal duration and then just
a general sense of performance and the
correct rejections but because those are
no signal trials alike not illuminated
there's not there
no signal duration to take into account
one other measures about the mentioning
on some of the slides is the vigilance
index and this is a measure of accuracy
sore overall accuracy on the test that
takes into account accuracy on signal
and non signal trials so one of the
experts on describe early on was used in
amino tox of 192 itt Sabourin this is a
toxin English as there's an antibody 192
igt that's coupled to a ribosome
inactivating and so 192 itg binds to the
p75 nerve growth factor receptor which
is located exclusively on called
cortically projecting cholinergic
neurons within the baseball brain so
this immunotoxin then binds to the p75
nerve growth factor receptor that
saccharine gets taken out via
endocytosis into the cell and then
safran can serve to inactivate ribosomes
leading to cell death so this is the way
to selectively lesion de cortically
projecting cholinergic neurons and then
examining affects unintentional
performance this early work there were
several papers that makati and starter
published loyal to this area's I've just
picked one of them here published in
1989 just to give you a general sense of
the typical findings so here this is a
measure of accuracy on the signal trials
or on an on signal trials and so what
you're seeing here is that this is the
Sham lesion animals are being depicted
right here and then the lesion animals
are below them and what you can see is
that the scene that the Sham lesion
animals are performing significantly
better than the leash and animals and
also when we look at correct projections
are showing a little bit of a decrease
here typically there's no effect seen on
correct rejection so it's a relatively
select to effect on signal duration that
gets conserved following cortical
cholinergic deafferentation until this
is important because it suggests that
the animals were just performing poorly
on all trials perhaps that there's they
just don't know the rules of the task
this suggests that the because there's
no significant effects on correct
protection the animals are still
responding based on the rules of the
task they simply are
worse on the signal trials so one of the
things that my lab became interests is
trying to understand whether their
specific task demands that might be
sensitive to loss of corals feel point
that is other specific aspects of the
cast that wind cholinergic neurons are
regions that they are important for the
deficits that magothy and sardar
observed so what we did was we had an
experiment which when animals are given
a coracle cholinergic the application is
that talked about earlier with 192 igg
safran what's being shown on the left
column here is what sham lesion animals
must study and on the right is a legion
danimal and so what you can see a lower
power along the top is a sense that
there's darker areas showing some of the
seed open esterase top fibers have been
staying for here submitters an example
of what i'm referring to and in the
lesion and also it's a little bit
lighter when we look at higher power
under magnification either in primary
motor cortex at primary somatosensory
cortex what you can see is quite a few
fibers and the Sham lesion animal
relatively few in lesion animals and
when we want to fight this we ended up
with about a seventy seven percent loss
on average in malaysia's coracle
cornered fibers in the lesion animals
relative to the Sham least animals so
then we train the animals in which we
minutes later a single aspect of the
task at a time so first we introduce Sam
lesion and lesion animals to a variable
signal duration we've been introduced
them to exclusively a shortened signal
duration to examine these specific
aspects of the task we're important for
reviewing deficits of lesion animals we
also buried the inner trial interval and
we tried decreasing the inner trial
animal as well and so overall what we
observe is when we limited any single
pass parameter we did not observe
deficits or differences in performance
between the lesion and the Sham lisha
camels however when we then turn the
animals on the full attention test with
the variable energy level and variable
signal durations
so basically the full task that I
described earlier rather than just
manipulating single parameters what we
observed is a significant decrease in
performance and the legion animals
compared to shame lesion animals so what
this suggests is that the it's something
about being the attentional demands of
the entire task and not any specific
component of it that's important for
revealing deficits of the lesion to
animals other experiments that we've
conducted to time look at the role this
is done it's part of my time when I was
in Martin sardars lab is to use
microdialysis to be able to sample
acetylcholine levels during attentional
past performance I'm sure many of you
audience are familiar with this this is
a procedure in which artificial
cerebrospinal fluid this precedes to an
inlet and be a semipermeable membrane
components like acetylcholine will move
from an area of higher concentration to
an area of lower concentration if
they're small enough to pass through the
membrane this can be collected through
an outlet and then quantum levels of
acetylcholine in our case to be
quantified using hplc and so this is
just showing you a sample here of a rat
being tested in that attention task team
but I was showing you earlier wall
tethered for microdialysis and so we
also train routes in some control tasks
as well because initially if we saw
elevation as you'll choline levels
during the attentional task performs
well there's a lot of factors that go
into that that task so the animals are
getting rewarded they're pressing lever
so it could just be the motor activity
or reward level that's important for
elevating field corn level so included
control tasks that next performance in
terms of amount of lever present the
animals did an amount of reward received
and those are described pairs are
attracting lever task in an f i9 tasks
that we use and so what you can see here
this is depicting baseline levels right
here of acetylcholine and all those
three different time wraps that were
trained in all three of those different
types of tasks no differences in
baseline levels and then when the tasks
were initiated you can see the dark bar
along the bottom near the
axis we saw a significant elevation and
acetylcholine levels even in our control
test that shows that was important to
include these cats because cortical
single polling levels are elevated even
by tasks with minimal explicit
attentional demand but the rather that
match in terms of I'm not a lover
pressing and reward the animals receive
however what we reserve what we observed
during attentional task performance is
that there is a significantly greater
elevation in clinical acetylcholine
levels during a tenant when animals are
poorly performing an attentional task
relative to the control test and so
overall with these lot of both line of
experimentation issue is that not only
does loss of the feeling disrupt
attentional performance but if we look
in the intact system and measure
acetylcholine levels while what animals
are performing the attention test but
including explicit attentional demands
will produce significantly more elevated
levels of cortical acetylcholine
compared with mashed control tasks so an
additional question that my lab is then
asking is to try to figure out the role
of corner dip receptors that might be
contributing to performance in these
tabs so essentially asking the question
what are the effects of blocking
different types of cholinergic receptors
and so what we initially did was we
administered systemically either a nikka
clinic receptor antagonist mecca domine
or a muscarinic receptor antagonist
kepala me and what you're seeing here is
measures of accuracy relative tickets
wrong [ __ ] clinic receptor blockade and
on the left panel we did not observe any
significant effects of blocking the
[ __ ] kinetic scepters unintentional
task performance it's possible that we
didn't use sufficiently high doses of
mecca melamine to observe effects so in
the figure on the right what I'm showing
you are the number of emissions per
session and across dose along the x-axis
and what you can see is that the highest
dose did significantly elevated
emissions which suggests that we were at
a sufficiently high dose we just didn't
observe differences in accuracy when the
nicotinic receptors are blocked we
looked at the effects of blocking
mushroom interceptor assists apollomon
relative hits along the y-axis here
signal duration along the x-axis what
you can see is that there's a
dose-dependent decrease in accuracy
following muscarinic receptor blockade
and so this let us serve up have to
focus on the muscarinic receptors more
specifically wearisome based upon the
literature that there is that because
the m1 receptors are largely located
postsynaptically that blocking those
receptors may be responsible for some of
the deficits that we observe with
scopolamine so we used a cycle mean at
different doses you can see along the x
axis relative it's along the y axis and
what we observe is at higher doses that
blocking at the m1 receptor with a typo
mean using systemic administration
impaired performance we went on to also
distract the animals by flashing a house
light in the back of the chamber
throughout the testing session and what
we observe which was interesting is that
even at lower doses when we observed
deficits previously we see declines and
performs so essentially by increasing
the attentional demand by distracting
the animals we shifted the dose response
curve so that the animals were now
showing deficits and performance at
lower doses compared with what we had
seen in our standard attention task in
which we're not distracting the animals
at the flashing house like we wanted to
know whether these effects were
centrally needed because these were IP
injections that we were doing and so
what we did was I into the lateral
ventricle we administered carrenza teen
an m1 receptor antagonist and we did see
us not huge effect they were
statistically reliable there's a
significant decrease and detecting the
longer signal durations when prendre
peen was administered I'm compared with
Vehicle Administration
as I'm sure all of you my audience know
those muscarinic receptors are
metabotropic receptors which means are
coupled to G proteins in the case of the
m1 receptor one of the things that's
activated following stimulation of this
receptor by acetylcholine is an
elevation of protein kinase c and so one
of the questions we didn't want it to
ask is if we what are the effects of
inhibiting protein kinase c on
occasional class performance so again
along the y-axis at showing actress am
signal trials percent ship's log signal
duration along the x-axis and so what
you can see is that the highest dose
will administer coloring chloride a pkc
inhibitor that we decrease performance
and our attentional task and because pkc
is located sort of when widespread areas
wanted to see whether this effect was
selective so we also looked at accuracy
on the non signal trials percent correct
rejections and we observed no effects
pkc inhibition on non signal trial so
this suggests much like little scene
earlier with in the earlier work with
selective lesions of protocol
cholinergic neurons what we observed is
that there's a selective decrease with
pkc inhibition on signal trials with no
effect on the non signal trials we then
wanted to look at the flip side of this
because we basically mapped out how we
should a pair them and muscarinic
receptor system all of em one receptor
system and then tkc so we wanted to flip
that around and see in lesion animals
could we reverse attentional deficits
when we administered an activator pkc
activator bio statin one and so what we
observe and i'll point out the
difference from vehicle here where the
lesion animals are performing worse than
the Sham lesion we administer low dose
of bio statin one we observe a
significant increase in performance in
the lesion animal so we're able to see
improvements in task performance of the
lesion animals following pkc activation
so we previously observed pkc innovation
disruptive performance here are pkc
activation can
enhanced performance of these animals we
also saw improved performance of the
Sham lesion animals at higher doses
we're still puzzling a little bit about
the nature of the dose response curve
but we are encouraged by the general
pattern of results that the but the
animals seem to be able to see improve
that show improvements in performance
following pkc activation we've also
looked at an m1 allosteric agonist I'm
not going to show you this data because
we didn't find any significant effects
when we used a m1 Alliser receptor
agonist so when we seem to see the
strongest beneficial effects or when we
activate pkc we also wanted to look at
regular another aspect of research in my
lab that we're interested in is looking
regulation of these basal forebrain
cholinergic neurons and so the pathway
that's being highlighted right here
originates within the hypothalamus and
projects to the basal four-lane the
system that we focused in on releases as
you know peptides call directions or
hypo creeks and these hypocretin
directions have been shown to women
fused into the basal forebrain to
elevate cortical acetylcholine release
so we were interested in whether the
system known to modulate asa for rank
cholinergic neurons would affect
attentional performance and so some of
our earlier works when we administered
SP drug SB to be able to impair erection
one or block erection 1 receptors and
what we observe is a decrease in
accuracy when we administered this drug
and you can see that dose the different
doses that were used in the in the
legends here and we looked at overall
performance the VI measure along the top
we saw a significant decrease in
performance and when we looked at
accuracy on signal versus non signal
trials I'm showing you the signal trial
accuracy here we observed a significant
decrease in performance on the signal
trials
we also observe I should have mentioned
on that previous life that was systemic
administration of the antagonist we also
looked at infusions directly into the
basal forebrain of erection one receptor
blockade and again chewing eevee I and
the figure along the top and relative
hits along the bottom of figure along
the bottom and we observed a significant
decrease in performance when we
administered an erection one receptor
antagonist into the basal forming so
that's suggested we were able to
localize the effects to the basal
forebrain we've also looked at the
effects of orexin a on attentional
performance so much like we looked at PK
Cena bishan and then pkc activation
we've also looked at the effects of
blocking orexin 1 receptors and then
stimulation of erection receptors with
the wrexham a and so along the top tier
this is a measure in which were we had
the session setups that there was an
initial block of 54 trials in which the
animals got our standard attention task
followed by a block of 54 trials from
lipstick presented that distractor will
be flashed the house line in the back of
the chamber and essentially what we're
looking at are different scores in terms
of performance during the distractor
compared minus performance during the
initial block of the standard attention
test and so what we observe here this is
just a reference the measure here so so
the distractor is producing later
decreases in accuracy when measures are
over in this part so when our above zero
some measures when it's a negative value
that suggests that they're doing better
during the distractor session and so
initially what we observe these are in
intact animals in which we administered
erection a into the lateral ventricle
and what we observed is that erection a
is able to reverse deficits and due to
the distractor an attentional task
performance that's being highlighted by
the asterisk and the line comparisons
here and we see this in our overall
measure our vigilance index or also
called the
is the f-18 is measure sustained
attention and on the bottom here i'm
showing you accuracy on signal trial
selectively relative hits and again just
like this in many of our other studies
this effect was largely due to changes
in accuracy on the signal trials so a
resume is able to when administered into
a lateral ventricle is able to reverse
deficits due to this factor finally we
also wanted to look lesion animals
whether we could reverse deficits due to
the distractor so this is a graph
showing the accuracy on the shortest
signal trials here and here when we
administered erection a what we observed
again is initially during vehicle
performance that these animals are more
affected by the distractors performing
worse compared to the Sham lesion
animals however when we administer
direction a the lesion animals benefited
more and we're now snow showing less of
an impairment during the distractor
session so overall these results do
suggest that erection a may be
beneficial and reversing attentional
deficits associated with dysfunctional
cholinergic cortical edel system so I
want to move to the second part of my
conscience I've described a lot of the
neural mechanisms that we focused on
looking at the role of Corrections and
different receptors of them the
cholinergic system to look at during
different studies related to different
no psychiatric conditions in which
attention is disrupted what are some of
the studies that we've conducted and
results that we found well one of the
things that we looked at is the role of
producing smaller lesions to the
cortical cholinergic system early in
life and adult low and assess whether as
the animals age their performance would
decline and this is related to ideas way
to Alzheimer's disease and which this
thought to be pathology of brain
difference it's occurring early on in
life it becomes exacerbated by the aging
process
so what we wanted to test is whether
partial damage to the cortical
cholinergic system would be sufficient
to lead to attentional deficits as the
animals age so the in terms of general
experimental design animals were trained
in that sustained attention test until
that I was describing earlier until age
16 month they were then administered 192
IDT saplin or see me and then test it
for the remainder of their lives in that
same measure potential and so what we
expected is that because they are
producing relatively small lesions using
a relatively low dose of being a toxin
we expected that we would end up with no
deficits and attentional components
early on right after the animals recover
but what we expect this at the age of
animals that show impairments later in
life and so this is just giving a sense
for the scoober the nature of the
lesions so the left column is depicting
a different magnifications the Sham
lesion animal and then on the right
column a legion animal and what you
notice is that it's a fairly dark in
terms of the Sham lesion panels but it's
not completely bleached out in the
column on the right so there are still
some silicone esterase positive fibers
and the column on the right when we want
to quantify this looking across
different cortical areas what we saw was
that our lesion to produce a loss of
about forty to sixty percent of cortical
corners input staring again a little bit
across different brain regions of course
we conduct these types of studies one of
the concerns is that perhaps the lesions
have just made the animal sick and that
they're not there's no selective deficit
in terms of attentional performance but
rather there's a there are issues just a
general help one way that we assess this
was by measuring the animal's body
weight throughout their lifespan and
what you can see here is if there's no
significant difference in body weight
between the Sham and the leaves and
animals
in terms of attentional performance
along the y axis showing about overall
measure of attentional performance
vigilance index and signal and signal
duration along the x-axis we tested the
animals immediately after surgery
there's no significant difference
between the sham and Leasing animals in
terms of their level of accuracy when we
compete to train the animals out to age
21 months and 26 months of age again we
did not observe any significant decrease
in accuracy and the legion animals
relative to the sham lesion animals
although you'll know at twenty six
months of aids we're starting to see a
slight dissociation between the two the
two groups we continue to train the
animals to 31 months of age what we
observe them VI along the y-axis here
signal duration along the x-axis at 31
months of age the lesion animal showed
an impairment relative to the Sham
leasing animals and accuracy on that
measure of attention and so when we
looked across lots of trials so what
block represents on the x-axis during
block one that's trials 1 254 during
block 2 12 55 2 108 and during bought 3
that's the last third of the trials 109
through a trial 162 and so what we
observed is evidence of a sustained
attention deficit in the lesion animals
when they were 31 months of age such
that they were significantly worse
during the third block of trials within
a testing session so basically as they
continue as the session continued the
Sham lesion animals showed no difference
in performance however the lesion
animals so a significant decline as the
testing session went on another approach
that we've taken is to try to understand
what a models of schizophrenia have
effects from attentional performance as
well and so we've looked at sort of the
two classic types of approaches looking
at a hyperactive dopamine system and an
underactive NMDA receptor system and so
what we did was in one study we looked
at this is percent also arm so this is
accuracy for the most part of the tide
by accuracy on the signal trials
these models in schizophrenia we're
looking at accuracy on non signal trial
and in fact what we see when we expose
the animals to amphetamine repeatedly
that they meet more errors on the non
signal trials who did not observe any
difference in accuracy on the signal
trials and animals that have been
repeatedly exposed to amphetamine
compared to those that have been
repeatedly had been repeatedly
administered saline look at the other
component if we block NMDA receptors
what we observe is no the figure on the
left here showing the accuracy on the
signal trials and there's no significant
difference between failing exposed
animals and those that were given that
nmda receptor antagonist MK 21 however
in the figure on the right depicting
false alarms when we look at
administration of MK 21 there's a
significant increase in the number of
false alarm when mk-801 is administered
relative to saline administration so one
of the things that we were interested is
in using an allosteric agonist at the
NMDA receptor d cyclo searing to try to
have beneficial effects in terms of
reversing deficits bong MK 21
administration here what I'm showing you
is administration of entirely vehicle
that I should mention this is percent
false alarms along the y-axis so you can
see what the false alarm rate was
following failing administration our
vehicle group and the animals that
receipt NK 21 they show the significant
increase in the hall swamp as we have
seen previously and the groups are given
MK 21 and disciple serine we observe a
reversal dose-dependent reversal in the
attentional deficits following mk-801
administration so this suggests that
there's potential for reversing these
types of deficits by acting at the NMDA
receptor further experiments in our lab
or looking at whether perhaps erections
are targeting the cholinergic system in
other ways could reverse some of these
deficits as well so some take-home
messages from my talk today
acetylcholine this hopeful at comincia
this critical for normal signal
detection and this attention to
income and we look at the different
receptor mechanisms involved the
muscarinic receptors appear to be
critically involved in mediating the
effects of acetylcholine on signal
detection on non signal trials this
appears to be more sensitive to
manipulation mimics relevant
neurotransmitter changes in
schizophrenia and so we're again doing
further work to try to assess how we
might be able to have beneficial effects
to reverse some of the attentional
deficit than those models of
schizophrenia and finally our work
suggests that may be able to target
protein kinase C or the erection system
in different ways to be able to have
beneficial effects and reversing
attentional deficits following various
manipulations I want to thank the
students in my lab would conduct to this
work I've had some very hardworking
undergraduate honor students who have
contributed to these projects and on the
bottom here are the graduate students
are highlighted bold who are responsible
for the work that I talked about today
I'd like to thank my collaborators on
these different projects more Arnold or
insider and especially timbales been a
longtime collaborator on the erection
work and I'd like to thank the funding
sources as well and now I'd be happy to
take any questions that you have thank
you so much for your presentation dr.
Burke we want to get right to everyone's
questions and input so here's a reminder
how to let us know what you would like
to ask questions can be submitted via
the Q&A button at the lower left if we
are unable to get to your questions due
to time constraints dr. Burke will
answer them by submitting the questions
via email so here is our first question
dr. Burke please describe expected
future directions for your research so I
think a large part of our work is better
understanding the role of the erection
system and attentional performance I
highlighted the work that we've done
looking at
someone receptors and erection a we
haven't yet looked at erection to
receptors or orexin be intentional
performance for conducting those
experiments now and so I think that's
going to be an important area for Easter
investigation in addition we've been
focusing on the erection inputs to the
basal forebrain but we haven't yet
studied and nobody's will characterize
the attentional effects erection ergic
inputs to for example the prefrontal
cortex so I think that are
characterizing those pathways will be
important in addition and I would say
look better understand the role second
messenger system given our data with
respect to protein kinase C is important
as well so that's another area for
future investigation and then trying to
understand whether these could be
targets potentially for conditions such
as all language diseases good friend
thank you so much another audience
number would like to know could you
discuss the role of nicotinic
cholinergic receptors in attention
please sure so one of the things that
surprising when we did some of the early
work was only block make a commit
receptor we did not observe substantial
effect on attentional class performance
and so nicotine as well understood to be
able to enhance attention so I think of
it as the muscarinic receptor system is
being the critical player for attention
and then the Nicky teneyck receptor
system may be a way to fine-tune
attentional processing this law so I
think of the two systems is working
together with the nicotinic receptor
system maybe not being absolutely
necessary but being wait to fine-tune
functions needed via the muskeg receptor
system in addition one of the ways that
i want to that connects the disconnects
is another aspect to my talk is that one
of the things that patients with
schizophrenia all regular do is smoke as
thought that they may be self-medicating
for cognitive deficits through nicotine
administration so one of the things that
were interested in as well as whether
the team which stimulates the eruption
system whether the erection system could
be a target for some of the continent
deficits in schizophrenia
thank you dr. Burke we have time for one
more question an audience number would
like to know what are some potential
side effects of activating the erection
system in an effort to improve
conditions associated with the
attentional deficits sure so one of the
some of the potential side effects of
activating your exit system or
disruption of sleep and increases in
anxiety so for example the wrexham
system when it's activated would be
expected to produce a organism that's
more alert and if this was taken for
example right before going to sleep it
certainly caused sleep difficulties so I
think some of the challenges will be
impact on sleep higher levels of
erections that the doses get if the
administration is given a dose too high
for a particular individual then what
could happen is that you have increases
in anxiety as well so I think those are
going to be some of the side effects
that need to be worked out and some of
the ways to do that might be through
better drugs are better able to target
allosteric sites on the erection
receptor so this is another area of
future directions and there hasn't been
there has been very little research and
drug development this area but I think
that could have a huge potential in
terms of having any sort of having more
than having beneficial effects while
minimizing the side effects
I would like to thank you again dr.
Burke for your presentation do you have
any final comments for the audience
before we well I just want to thank lab
groups again for the opportunity to talk
with you about this work and if anybody
would like to contact me to hear more
because I certainly didn't describe all
the details and the projects you have a
lot of papers were showing up there but
if you have any additional questions
about the nature of our research I'd be
happy to talk further thank you again
dr. Burke I would like to thank lab
groups for making today's educational
webcast possible today's webcast will be
available on-demand viewing through june
sixteenth 2017 keep an eye out for an
email from lab roots alerting you win
this webcast will be available for
replay we encourage you to forward the
announcements to your colleagues and
that didn't get a chance to be today at
today's live event thank you again for
joining us and hope to see you next time
bye bye